- [Voiceover] So we've just
computed a vector-valued
partial derivative of a
vector-valued function,
but the question is What does this mean?
What does this jumble
of symbols actually mean
in a more intuitive geometric setting?
And that has everything to do with
how you visualize the function,
and with this specific function,
given that the input is two-dimensional
but the output is three-dimensional,
meaning the output has more
dimensions than the input,
it's nice to visualize it
as a parametric surface.
And the way that I do that,
maybe you could call this visualizing it
as a transformation also
'cause what I want to do is
basically think of the TS plane,
think of the TS plane
where all these input values live
and kind of think of how that's gonna map
into three-dimensional space,
but when I do that, I'm actually
gonna cheat a little bit.
Rather than having a
separate plane off there
as the TS plane, I'm
going to kind of overwrite
onto the XY plane itself
and plop the TS plane down like this,
and this isn't the full TS plane.
This is actually supposed to represent
just values of T that range
from zero up to three,
so each tick mark on the graph
here corresponds with a half.
So this is one, that's two,
and then up here is three.
Same with S.
S also ranges from zero to three,
and the reason that I'm plopping it
inside three-dimensional
space to start with,
kind of overwriting the XY
plane with the TS plane,
is just to make the animating
a little bit easier.
You could call it laziness.
But the benefit here is what we can do
is watch each point, and
each one of these points
you're thinking of is corresponding
to some kind of TS pair,
an input point, which is
just a pair of numbers,
and we're gonna watch
each one of those points
move to the corresponding output.
The output is a three-dimensional value,
a three-dimensional vector or point,
however you wanna think about it,
and what that looks like when
we animate this actually is
each one of those points
in our square of TS plane
moves to the corresponding output,
and you end up with a certain surface.
And just to make it a
little more concrete,
what's actually going on here,
let's focus in on just one point,
and we'll focus in on this point
not just for the function visualization
but for the partial derivative as well,
and the function, or the point rather,
that I care about is gonna be at one, one.
So this point right here represents
the pair of TS
where each one of them is equal to one.
One, one.
And you can start by
predicting where you think
this is gonna get output,
and to do that, you just
plug it into the function.
This is kind of what
the visualization means
as we're plugging this in,
and for T and S, we're gonna
plug in just one and one.
So that top part is gonna
look like one squared
minus one squared, which becomes zero.
That middle part is gonna be
one times one, which is one,
and then over here we're gonna
have one times one squared,
which is one minus one
times one times one squared,
which is, again, one.
And you can probably see,
'cause of the symmetry there,
those also cancel out, you get zero,
which means the output
corresponding with this input
should be the vector zero, one, zero,
a vector that's of unit length
pointing in the Y direction.
So if we look here, this is the X axis.
This here is the Y axis.
So you would think it should be a vector
that looks kind of like this.
Unit vector in the Y direction,
and the point of the
surface is what corresponds
to the tip of that vector.
This is how we visualize
parametric things.
You just think of the tip of the vector
as kinda moving through space
and drawing out the thing.
In this case, the thing
it's drawing is a surface.
So if we watch that animation again
and we let things play forward,
that dot corresponding
with the input one, one
does indeed land at
the tip of that vector.
So, at least for that value,
you can see that I'm not lying
to you with the animation.
And in principle, you could do
that for every single point.
If any given input point, you
plug it through the function,
and you draw the vector in
three-dimensional space,
as you watch this animation,
it'll land at the tip of that vector.
So...
Now, if we want to start thinking about
what the partial derivative means,
remember this little DT, this partial T,
is telling you to nudge
it in the T direction.
So what does movement,
not even nudges but just
movement in general,
look like in the T direction
for our little snippet
of the TS plane here?
Well, the T direction,
I'm saying is in this direction here
where this represents one,
two, three of T values,
and this line here represents
the constant value for S,
so this would be S
constantly equaling one,
which you can know because
it's passing through
the point one, one.
And then otherwise you're
just letting T range freely.
And if we watch how this gets transformed
under the transformation,
under the mapping to
the parametric surface,
you can get a feel for
what varying the input T
does in the output space.
So this whole pink line
is basically telling you
what happens if you let
S constantly equal one
but you let the variable T,
the input T, vary freely,
and you get a certain curve
in three-dimensional space.
And if you had a different constant for S,
it would be another curve,
and maybe you can kinda
see on the grid lines
what shape those other curves would have,
and they're all, in a sense, parallelish
to this curve corresponding
to S equals one.
So if, instead of thinking
about movement of T as whole,
you start thinking about nudges,
this whole partial T
is something where we're just imagining
a tiny, tiny, little
movement in the T direction.
Not really that much,
just a tiny, little move.
It's like you're recording
its value as partial T,
so maybe, if you're being concrete,
you'd say partial T would
be something like 0.01.
And really it's gonna
be a limiting variable
that gets smaller and smaller,
but I find it's kind
of nice to think about
an actual value like one one-hundredth.
And then if you let this whole thing
undergo the transformation
and we kind of watch the input point,
watch the line representing T,
that little nudge, that little nudge
is gonna get maybe stretched or squished,
and it's gonna result
in some kind of vector
pointing along that curve,
and it'll be tangent to that curve.
The vector that tells you how you move
just a tiny, tiny little bit
will be tangent in some way,
and that vector, that output nudge,
is what you're thinking
of as your tiny change
to the output vector, that partial V.
And when you divide it by the tiny value,
if your tiny value was 0.01
and you divide it by that,
it's gonna become something bigger,
so the actual derivative isn't gonna be
just some tiny, little nudge
that's hardly, hardly visible,
but it's gonna be that nudge
vector scaled appropriately.
In this case, it would be
divided by one one-hundredth
and multiplied by 100,
and it would be something that
remains tangent to the curve,
but maybe it's pointing big.
And the larger it is, the longer it is,
that's telling you that as you let T vary
and you're kind of moving
along this pink curve,
tiny nudges in T correspond
with larger movements.
The ratio of the nudge size is bigger.
So if you were to have a very
long partial derivative vector
that's still tangent but
really goes out there,
that would tell you that as you vary T
you're zipping along super quickly.
And if we just look at this particular one
that's zooming off of one,
you kind of get a feel for
the curve around that point.
You say, "Okay, okay."
And that curve, you're moving
positively in the X direction.
You're moving to the right.
You're moving positively
in the Z direction.
Not Z, sorry, the Y.
Positively in the Y direction up there.
And the Z direction is
actually negative, isn't it?
This curve kind of goes down
as far as Z is concerned.
So before even computing it,
if I were to tell you
that I'm gonna plug in
the value one, one to
this partial derivative
that we computed in the last video,
you would say, "Oh, well,
just looking at the picture,
"you can kind of tell that the X value
"is gonna be something positive,
something greater than zero."
The Y value is also gonna
be something positive,
and, again, that's because
the movement is to the right,
so positive X.
It's moving up, so positive Y,
but the Z value should actually
be a little bit negative
because as you look at this curve,
it's going down in a sense.
And with that being our prediction,
if you start plugging
in one, one to T and S,
what you'll see is that
two times one is two,
S equals one, so that's just one,
and then over here this
looks like one squared
minus two times one times one,
so this will be one minus two.
That's negative one, so
it is in fact that kind of
positive, positive, negative
pattern that you were seeing.
And maybe even from this curve,
you can get a feel for why the
movement in the X direction
is twice as much in the movement in the Y.
It's moving more to the right
than it is up in the Y direction.
Then, again, in principle
you can imagine doing this
not just at the point one,
one but at any given point,
maybe any given point along this curve
or any given point along the surface.
And the corresponding movement,
the direction that nudges
in the T direction,
will give you some vector
in three-dimensional space,
and that's the interpretation.
That is the meaning of
the partial derivative
of the vector-valued function here.
And, again, it's not the
actual nudge vector itself,
when you nudge the input
and you get just a little
smidgen in the output space here,
but it's that divided by
the size of the nudge,
so that's why you'll get
kind of normal-sized vectors
rather than tiny vectors.
And in the next video, I'll
do kind of the same thing
for what happens when you
nudge in the S direction
just to get a better
feel for what's going on
in this example.